des voitures encore des voitures
toujours des voitures ça c'était lyon 3e
ville de france dans les années 60 et sa
selle aujourd'hui toujours des voitures
des klaxons des voitures dans tous les
sens
le quotidien des riverains et
automobilistes de la presqu'île
mais ça devrait changer à partir de
septembre la presqu'île un quartier
central de lyon sera réservée aux
piétons
un samedi par mois seulement la
piétonnisation du centre-ville reste un
processus lent très lent
a lyon les premières expérimentations
date de 1976 c'est ainsi qu'en quelques
mois ce qui apparaissait comme une
utopie réalisée à l'époque pour trouver
un centre ville entièrement libérées des
voitures il fallait se rendre en
allemagne au début des années soixante
dix munich possédait la plus grande zone
piétonne d'europe une aspiration cours
ou en ville pionnière en france c'est
tout un quartier d'euros qui devrait
changer de visage le quartier de la
france c'est en fait tous les personnes
de la capitale leur manque que l'on veut
sauver paris ne pouvait pas être en
reste des zones piétonnes apparaissent
au début des années 70 rue princesse ou
rue saint benoît au quartier latin comme
un montmartre autour de la place du
tertre
il est maintenant impossible à l'homme
tronc automobile devenir promener ses
pneumatiques
montpellier faisait aussi partie des
villes avant gardiste en 1972 la ville
s'aventure à interdire quelques rues du
centre voiture mais les municipalités
successives y prennent goût étant de la
zone c'est la course aux records
montpellier qui est certainement la
ville qui possède le plus de rues
piétonnes et de places privées de la
circulation automobile trente neuf mille
mètres carrés à ce jour sont à la
disposition des piétons
autre ville a repoussé les voitures
strasbourg ça commence aussi dans les
années 70 avec ce quartier hautement
touristique
enfin le centre de la petite france et
libérer les voitures ou presque le
secteur piétonnier à pénétrer la rue des
dentelles l'impasse des roses mais bien
d'autres encore en tout à strasbourg 21
1500 m² livrés aux piétons le secteur
s'agrandit en 1994
c'est au tour de la place kléber voici
la place kléber film et il y a quatre
ans et est un gigantesque carrefour ou
50000 véhicules alimentés chaque jour un
peu plus la pollution et les nuisances
revoici la même place aujourd'hui les
strasbourgeois et les touristes ont
repris possession du lieu
les centre ville piétonnier sont légion
aujourd'hui mais une commune en espagne
a fait le choix le plus radical cette
vie sans voiture est devenu le quotidien
des 83 mille habitants de pontevedra
il y a quinze ans trente mille véhicules
traversaient chaque jour le centre ville
jusqu'à ce que le maire décide de faire
de pontevedra la première ville sans
voitures au mans en réalité seule la
moitié de la ville est entièrement
interdite aux véhicules particuliers
mais en vingt ans la réduction des
émissions de co2 a baissé des deux tiers
qu'une performance
[Musique]